i'm answering the most complicated and
maybe some of the funniest questions
that sam picked out for me and huge
thank you to thrive market for
sponsoring this video
are bones wet or dry
they have blood vessels inside them
they're blood there's blood so they're
wet actually they're spongy and if
something's spongy it's more likely to
be wet than not
does being slapped actually wake you up
or is that a cartoon thing it absolutely
does wake you up you know what wakes you
up more than a slap a sternal rub we
actually do that in the hospital to our
patients the sternum is a bone if you
rub it very aggressively like that it'll
wake a patient up that's how we check if
they're actually unconscious or awake or
just asleep what is the leg version of
your armpit called uh
it has a name
now palpatine here see sometimes even
doctors forget terms it's the palpateal
area palpatiul fossa is it dangerous to
eat apple stems my friend eats the
entire apple and i'm afraid she's gonna
hurt herself i've never heard of apple
stems being dangerous to eat i know i
really don't want to eat the seeds
what's wrong with the seeds i'm pretty
sure they contain some kind of
anti-phytonutrient or something let's
see apple seeds can be indeed poisonous
from britannica.com but it takes quite a
few of them to kill you and they have to
be crushed
adult would need to eat 150 to several
thousand to be at the risk of cyanide
poisoning wow
interesting the more you know is it true
that if you step on crack you break your
mama's back or if you step on a line
break your daddy's spine
i don't know what kind of bondage
question this is but no i don't know why
there's drugs mentioned in this you
shouldn't be stepping on crack because
it's illegal you shouldn't be stepping
on a line break i don't know what that
means do you know where what this is
from no oh how funny
it's when you walk on the sidewalk it's
a game kids play step on a crack you
break your mother's back whoa this is
some american stuff
yeah i grew up here you see while these
guys were playing that game i was
learning arithmetic see my daddy was
breaking my spine if i didn't get the
arithmetic right
barely alive hey dr mike what do you
think about developing birth control for
men absolutely necessary uh there are
already some options out there so we
need to do more of that do you ever use
your medical training on non-humans like
bear absolutely joshua whenever bear is
sick i'm trying to figure out what's
wrong with him in the same way that i do
with the human even when i go to the vet
i ask very pointed questions and they're
like are you in healthcare i'm like i'm
a family doctor and bears family so you
better take care of him like family get
me april should i put on sunscreen
before or after i apply my makeup ah
that's a really good question
well if we take this logically you want
to apply the sunscreen directly to your
skin so that it gets absorbed and does
its job protecting your body from uv
rays then you could put the makeup on on
top of the sunscreen but the sunscreen
has to come on first also remember you
have to reapply quite often especially
if you're swimming and or toweling i
love that word cowling say with me
toweling if your eye muscles are active
all day and during your rem cycle when
do they rest it's a cycle so they're not
constantly going throughout the night
there are periods where there's non-rem
sleep and your eye muscles are relaxed
also it's important to note that
different muscles have different
utilities and some need more rest than
others your cardiac muscle almost never
gets a break during the short time that
it relaxes but your heart beats maybe a
hundred thousand times a day on average
it's a lot of work and it doesn't stop
when you sleep or when you sneeze
myth busted hey doc are you considering
getting another tattoo me i am i think i
have what i want but i don't know where
i want it so i'm open to suggestions it
is text so feel free to text on my body
right now and send me a tweet of what
you've texted on me can i use chopsticks
absolutely i'm a chopstick rock star i
can all day i can eat soup with
chopsticks are you on that level back to
the questions in just a second but first
let me tell you about thrive market an
online marketplace where you can save
money and get amazing products the
beauty of thrive market is there are
thousands of items with guaranteed
savings home beauty even pet products
for bear with a price match guarantee
recently i've been using their new auto
ship feature created so i never run out
of the things i need like these
chocolate covered almonds one of my
favorite snacks i love that when i'm
browsing the website you can organize it
based on the diet or values that are
important to you non-gmo fair trade
certified vegan whatever you need it's
there all orders are delivered with
carbon neutral shipping and their
warehouses are zero waste a part of
thrive market's mission to become the
world's first climate positive grocery
store choose whatever membership best
fits your lifestyle one month 12 month
packages for me the 12 month package at
just five dollars per month is really
the reasonable choice and that's the one
i recommend to my friends and family
join thrive market today and get 40 off
your first order and a free gift all you
have to do is visit the link down below
thrive market dot com dr mike remember
doctor is spelled out and if you sign up
for the full year it's 30 days risk free
all right let's get back to the
questions why does your funny bone
tingle when you touch it or whatever
well if yours tingles just when you
touch it there's a problem there's some
inflammation in your cubital fossa in
your cubital tunnel i'm fossa everywhere
today in your cubital tunnel here when
you hit your funny bone here's what's
actually happening and i'm gonna blow
your mind right now because the funny
bone ain't even a bone it's actually the
ulnar nerve that runs in the cubital
tunnel here that leaves your spine comes
down your arm and comes and gives
sensation and motor control to your
hands and unlike regular pain which is
like achy throbby sharp nerve pain like
if you damage the nerve directly what
you're getting is electrical shooting
awkward pain tingly that feels weird are
there certain foods or drinks that can
induce dreams while you sleep i'm gonna
take this question a little differently
medications
can definitely change the types of
dreams that you have i'll give you a
personal example if i was to take
benadryl before going to sleep i have
the craziest deepest dreams like i will
go into a murder mystery with bear as my
psychic and him and i talk and we solve
the mystery together
it happened victoria b the lemons make
you lose weight
are you asking that facetiously if you
put two lemons in your pocket do you
lose weight if you put two lemons in
your stomach do you lose weight no
lemons have nothing to do with weight
loss in fact lemons if you eat them have
calories in them so if you eat enough of
them you can gain weight with lemons
why is it when you smell something
really bad it makes you want to throw up
that's probably an evolutionary thing
that you've developed to make you stay
away from that object because nausea is
a very powerful deterrent if it's
already in your mouth why you throw up
is because your body probably senses
something there's a muck there and
shouldn't be entering your body and
actually encourages you to get rid of it
can a person with epilepsy still work in
the hospital absolutely it obviously
depends on whether or not their epilepsy
is controlled because you can't be
working with tools if your epilepsy is
uncontrolled so if you're taking the
medications and you have a documented
history of having it controlled you can
have many jobs mike you've only broken
one bone why are you playing it so safe
you're right neil let me go break some
is there a difference between cpr and
chest compressions cpr just means
cardiopulmonary resuscitation chest
compressions are part of that we used to
give rescue breaths but we realized that
there wasn't enough benefit to doing so
it actually stopped people from
performing the chest compressions which
are actually the most important thing to
increase someone's survivability until
help arrives bronwyn s is it safer to
wear over ear or in-ear headphones oh
i'm very passionate about this first of
all if you are cycling or running
outside and there are motor vehicles
around make sure you do not use noise
cancelling headphones it will save your
life second if you use in-ear headphones
and you have earwax earwax gets pushed
further and further further back and
then it starts clogging yours which can
lead to you developing an infection when
you're listening with your headphones
whether they're on ear or in ear or over
the ear headphones make sure that you're
listening to less than 60
volume because you will damage your
hearing over time if you continue
listening above 60
dr mike can you recommend a great source
of protein i'm trying to body build zeta
depends uh i'm a big fan of getting your
protein naturally from foods ideally
healthy foods beans nuts uh white meat
chicken soy whey protein could be an
option for some although it doesn't vibe
with everyone's guts some people do have
upset stomach with it does cold weather
actually give people colds nope false
misinformation but it does increase the
susceptibility of colds because if you
are very cold and aren't dressed right
that can hurt your immune system also in
the wintertime the air is more dry
therefore drying out your mucous
membranes and the fun part that i like
to talk about most is germ hang time
when the air is dry you sneeze into the
air the germs hang around a lot longer
austin graham hey dr mike why is eating
salt so bad i hear about people having
to reduce their sodium intake it's not
inherently bad we need to stop
villainizing nutrients because it
creates so many other problems here's
the best nutrients and here are the
worst nutrients it doesn't exist it
depends on who you are and what problems
you have if you have congestive heart
failure and you already have high blood
pressure yeah you should monitor your
salt intake because that could be a
problem but in general be reasonable
listen to the guidance that your doctor
has given you as an individual as
opposed to reading nonsense articles
online that usually doesn't apply to you
why is it when you get up too fast you
get lightheaded all right fun question
about orthostatic hypotension your body
has a blood pressure that it needs to
maintain in order to keep blood going
from the lower part of your body against
gravity and feeding your brain right
because your brain's at the top gravity
is pulling your blood down when you
stand up you suddenly need to raise your
blood pressure very quickly in order to
make sure that the blood keeps reaching
the brain so your body has to do is it
has to sense that change of pressure
really quickly and adjust by squeezing
the arteries in your legs in order to
shoot that blood back up into your brain
now
now now now now now if you're a little
bit older if you're a little dehydrated
you can't maintain a good enough blood
pressure or you can't adjust your blood
pressure as quickly you will feel a
little lightheaded when you get up and
that's why you should get up slowly and
you should always have support make sure
you don't fall how do you know if you
have high blood pressure please answer
please answer
i can tell you have high blood pressure
from reading
your question here in all caps you
measure your your blood pressure using a
sphygmomanometer is that how you say it
i thought it was this big nominometer
such an important point one elevated
blood pressure measurement does not
equal the diagnosis of hypertension or
high blood pressure that is simply an
elevated blood pressure reading without
the diagnosis of hypertension because it
takes multiple little davey dr mike i
have to meet you when can we make this
happen come on tour
details down below seriously tickets are
selling out fast and if you wanna meet
you gotta you gotta get a ticket i see
those drawer trainer things on tick tock
till they actually work bro cristiano
ronaldo got paid mad money to do that ad
and you shouldn't really be using these
things because the master muscles are
really strong but the reality is if you
overdo it you can create problems in the
tmj area that literally literally cause
you to have a pain in the head not a
pain in the butt but a pain in the head
and then at night if you over train
these muscles you can start doing teeth
clenching and teeth grinding wearing
down your molars you do not want these
problems trust me on this i've seen
patients who suffer with it it's a big
big problem
click here for a video about birth
control literally the best birth control
and huge thanks again to thrive market
for sponsoring this video join thrive
market today to get 40 off your first
order and a free gift use my link to get
started and as always stay happy
you